-Steve Carell.
-Wow.
-It's so good to see you, buddy.
-I am really something.
-You really are something.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for doing
"Go On, Git."
I appreciate that.
-Oh, my gosh, no problem.
-I love doing any sketch work
with you.
Any time we do a bit together,
it always makes laugh.
-That's --
Those are our roots.
-Yeah, that's right.
You started in Second City...
-Yeah.
-...doing sketch comedy.
Any characters you remember
doing over there?
-A lot of forgettable things.
The one thing that --
[ Laughter ]
No, I mean, a lot of
it's just very disposable.
-Yeah.
-You know, you do it one night,
and then you never see it again,
or you think about it,
but it never comes back.
There was one character
I was working on,
and it was a guy who --
It was a poker scene, and I kept
trying to get it into the show.
It never went into a show.
It was a poker scene,
and the guy, and all of his
friends, are talking about sex.
And they're trying to regale
each other with these --
you know, these stories
of sexual conquest.
And my guy didn't
have any sort of context.
You know, no frame of reference,
and obviously was trying to lie.
So that became
"40-Year-Old Virgin."
-Really?
-That whole idea --
Yeah, Judd Apatow,
after we did "Anchorman,"
he came to me and said,
"Hey, would you like to,
you know, get together?
Do you have any ideas to pitch?"
And we got together,
I pitched all these other ideas,
and just before I left, I said,
"You know what?
There's one more.
There was this thing I was
kind of trying to get going
at Second City
that never went anywhere."
-No way.
-He heard that, and he said,
"That I could sell, like,
immediately."
And the next week, he talked
to an executive, sold it.
We wrote it.
It got greenlit.
It was like -- it was -- yeah.
-The rest is history.
From a character that never made
it to stage at Second City.
-Right. Yeah.
-I wanted to show you something.
I found something funny
on the Internet.
This is going around.
People say --
They send me things all the time
and say people look like me
and all that stuff.
Someone says you have
a doppelganger out there.
And I don't know if you've ever
seen this, but it's pretty good.
People say that
you look like Alice Cooper.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Not bad.
-Yeah.
♪♪
Yeah.
-It's kind of fantastic.
-I see it.
-In that photo --
that's a perfect photo,
right there, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Have you ever met Alice Cooper?
-I met Alice Cooper.
I waited on him
when I was working in Chicago.
-Did you really?
-When I was waiting tables.
Yeah, I was working
at a restaurant.
He came in, and, he was --
you know, he was Alice Cooper.
-Yeah.
-And couldn't have been nicer.
Sweetest guy in the world.
-That is the thing
about Alice Cooper.
I've met him once before, too,
and he could be whatever.
-Yeah.
-He could be a rock guy
who's like, "Whatever, man."
He is the nicest human.
-Nicest guy.
And I go, "Oh, my God.
I love Alice Cooper.
I just want to hang out
with the guy."
But, I mean,
he walks into a room,
and he's unmistakably
Alice Cooper.
-Yeah.
-Steven Tyler is from an area
that I live in in Massachusetts,
and he always dresses
like Steven Tyler.
He wears, like, you know,
leopard-skin pants,
and he walks around these --
This little town
outside of Boston.
And he goes
into the Dunkin' Donuts,
buys doughnuts for everybody.
He's like, "Ooh-ahh, doughnuts!"
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He's got scarves and stuff.
-But he's like the nicest guy.
The same thing.
-Yeah. How do they do that?
-I think they own it.
I think you have to own --
If you're Alice Cooper, you have
to own being Alice Cooper.
-Yeah. 'Cause that's --
-You own being Steven Tyler.
-That's who he is.
-Yeah.
-Anyone else famous
that you waited on?
-I've only --
You're the only other famous
person I've ever met.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so happy.
-I waited on --
Do you remember --
A lot of your audience
won't know this reference.
Remember Clara Peller?
"Where's the beef?"
-"Where's the beef?" lady.
-Yeah.
-Oh, Clara Peller.
Oh, my gosh.
You waited on Clara Peller?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-[ Gasps ]
And guess what she ordered.
-Please don't say a hamburger.
-A hamburger!
-Wow!
♪♪
-Yeah.
And she had the biggest
entourage I have ever seen.
[ Laughter ]
She had like 20 people.
-20 people, yeah.
-Oh, yeah.
-And like, "Hey, by the way,
she's not gonna say it."
-"Don't ask her to say it."
-"Don't ask her to say it.
She's not gonna say it."
And then you go,
"Come on, Clara."
-"Come on.
Give me one.
Just give me a little
"Where's the beef?"
-Where's the beef?
That's so good.
-I want to talk about
"Minions: Rise of Gru."
This one -- I told you
backstage, I really mean it --
is I think this one's
my favorite one.
I love all of them, but this
one's a fantastic movie.
Crushed in front of my kids.
-Oh, good.
-They loved it so much.
But I loved it, as well.
Do people come up to you
and ask you to do Gru for, like,
a voicemail for their kids.
-Definitely for that.
I don't like to do it, like,
especially around little kids,
because to associate --
You don't want to associate me
with that voice.
-They don't get it.
-It's a little confusing.
-A little, like,
"What is this guy doing?
That's not -- it's him."
But friends, and I've done it
for charities and stuff,
to leave a voice message.
And, like, this friend of mine,
their son Dylan,
"Oh, it's his birthday.
Could you leave a message
as Gru."
"Hi, Dylan, I hope you have
a terrible birthday!"
[ Laughter ]
"Be a good kid
and brush your teeth."
[ Laughter ]
And I remember --
So, the mom called me
the day after and said,
"You know what?
He looked at me
after I played that message and
said, 'Mom, see? He's real.'"
-Oh, see? Come on.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, that's the coolest thing.
-In this one, you play Gru
at like a 12-year-old
or an 11-year-old.
-Yeah.
-And how did you
find that voice?
The younger Gru.
-Oh, it was so,
so difficult, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "How do I do this?"
-Yeah, how do you do --
-Oh, I'll go from this...
[ High-pitched voice ]
...to this.
[ Laughter ]
-There you go. That's amazing.
-See?
-Do you mind leaving a word --
-Thank you.
-Can you leave a message
for my --
My daughter's birthday's
in September -- as young Gru.
-[ Laughs ]
-No.
You brought, actually,
your son to the premiere,
who, your son, I can't even
believe now, is 18.
-18, yeah.
-I can't believe that.
-Yeah, my son, 18,
my daughter, 21,
came to the premiere.
And they wanted to go.
It wasn't like, "Please, come."
They were the ones who --
No, seriously.
-It was never "Please, come"?
-No, no, for me -- I wasn't,
like, begging them to come.
I was like, "I get it.
If you think it's a kids movie,
and you don't want to -- I get
it if you don't want to come."
They've grown up with it.
They love it.
They love the whole series.
They were 4 and 7
when the first one came out.
So they really --
-And they helped you
get the voice.
-They helped pick the voice,
yeah.
I tried out
some different voices,
and that's the one
that made them laugh.
But, yeah, it was so cool
to have them there.
And they loved it.
-Yeah.
I want to show everyone a clip.
It is a great movie.
Here's Steve Carell
in "Minions: The Rise of Gru."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Oh! Not now!
Come on!
-Aah!
-[ Shouts ]
[ Metal crunching ]
-Oh!
-Hyah!
-[ Grunts ]
[ All shouting ]
-Aah!
[ Crashing ]
[ Tires screech ]
-Yeah, baby.
Aha!
I'll handle this.
-Wha!
-Aah!
-[ Laughing ]
[ Grunts ]
♪♪
-Hope you enjoy
the rest of your short life.
-Please work.
Come on, come on, come on.
-[ Gasps ]
-Yeah!
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
Steve Carell, everybody!
"Minions: The Rise of Gru"
is in theaters this is Friday.